april aufnehmen wir können sehen wollt
ich selber statt
wir sind einfach eine treppe eigentlich
wenn man es richtig aber dann wärst hier
die nao geschossen wenn man so so wär
schön da zusammengekommen ist kann sagen
die backen kochen und da haben
gesprochen bewegung versteht
hallo leute hier ist wieder eure als ob
du so macht handeln müssen wir das mal
wann es ist alles zu dritt hallo leute
ich ist wieder einmal wann und wo kommen
zu einer neuen folge drei cocktails für
die dia dachte sie bieten drei cocktails
beklagen es ist zwar noch nicht ostern
es ist doch nicht ostern aber wir sind
schon richtig in unser stimmung oder mit
unseren füßen haben habt ihr lust auf
das video
ihr habt den titel wahrscheinlich schon
gelesen heute machen wir drei eierlikör
kauft hält passend zur osterzeit und
dafür habe ich sogar selber eierlikör
gemacht nur mit das ist einmalig mit
alkohol und ohne alkohol für vincent wir
probieren einmal nerven nicht wir müssen
gucken womit wir arbeiten ich habe das
gestern selbst gemacht das ist anstatt
ein paar wochen haltbar
bei dem mit alkohol ist rum drin sie gar
nicht so schlecht hier hat auch eine
bude schuldige war
welcome back
ich finde ihn sehr sehr gut
die selbst gut verlinkt durch das rezept
dafür gerne in der infobox trainieren
es ist schon auch sehr stark aber
trotzdem nicht zu stark ja man sieht ihm
ein wohlschmeckendes aber das ist normal
da schmeckt dass wir dieses und andere
geschmäcker nach bisher so so
in seiner verraten anni hat denen
gemacht und dann hat sie gesagt warum
hat es überhaupt vanille drin was nützen
die vanille zugangs wie viel eine
packung ist an ihrem telefon
wir müssen doch den papieren mit schritt
von dem erhalten habt ihr noch ein jahr
dann aber auch schon stark dass sein
dass ich mag das gesicht wieder trinken
[Musik]
er hat kein wind sind und hast sogar mit
monsanto spanisch kombi
dieser ist nicht so denn kann schreibt
mir das auch das wird nach behafteten
sexy denn nicht so shirt aufdruck so und
jetzt probieren wir noch einen
supermarkt eierlikör und einfach nur den
vergleich zu haben
danach wären frauen absolut willig habe
ich mir sagen lassen
also du kannst diese hefte ist freilich
sagen wie es ist ja genau das richtige
für den gemütlichen fernsehabend von
annika kann man ja auch nicht betrogen
werden das ist ja eigentlich kann man da
hin da kann man vieles drin
und wie schmeckt 20 aber es schmeckt
wirklich gut jetzt macht ein gesicht als
ob du es dir schmecken würde ein 23
die zutaten zu sagen was nicht ich will
keine laktose drin
soll ich das irgendwie erwähne sie nicht
freundin kelly sein
gestellt jetzt unsere zutaten vor
unsere erste kandidatin ist naomi john
naomi liebt süße sachen ihre zwei katzen
chili und takko und alkohol
jetzt stellt sie uns ihre zutaten vor
wir haben es selber gemacht dann als
nächsten tag den weißen raum bad vilbel
frucht als nächste früchte erdbeeren
habe ich noch ein paar mehr früchte aber
diesmal tiefgefroren
dann den sauerkirschen brachte nichts
bringt dann noch die friedfertige schlag
war wieder spritzig extrem langsam
[Musik]
meine wichtigste zutat jetzt gleich für
alle ein bisschen komisch an aber ab
er verspielte vegetarier vincent ist
nicht nur ein verrücktes vögelchen
sondern auch der perfekte partner für
verträumte vorauszahlungen
hier kommen seine zutaten ich hatte
denselben gedanken deswegen wollte ich
diesmal die wichtigsten kompetenzen sind
ganz wichtig so prof
ganz wichtig ist auch die jeden
mandelmilch und tremoli ich hab die
müssen nach einer normalen shop trinken
ein
das ding ist dass er heil lecker ja
schon sehr süß ist es angelegenheit um
die süße noch ein bisschen zu steigern
habe ich noch nie erlebt unsere weiße
blüten passten
jetzt freuen wir uns aber auf seine
zutaten angesagt danke also meinen hut
haben sind heute ein dickes ei was ist
so groß geraten wo ist was einen großen
sein das ist ganz in kuba baileys in
choco dann natürlich den eierlikör
bekommen es ohne zucker ein glücklicher
sogar schrittweise schmetterlinge
konfetti und dem dresdner krönchen und
sieht einfach aus cuxhaven
woher weißt du denn nico popp sieht da
draußen kux uns auch schon wieder
hast du mich letzten mal auch ein jahr
vorschlagen
das mag ich habe noch den bann und man
weiß dass das ein kind gemacht und
fermentation und dann wünsche ich eine
fröhliche osterzeit willkommen bei
[Musik]
würden die durch spiele ich bin schon
ein bisschen eingebildet davon und ich
sagen auf leeren magen schon lange her
sagt eigentlich dazu dass die vollen
jahr verschoben wird als man die hatten
ein erdbeben
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
nimmst du noch auf vanessa sich zu sehen
[Musik]
haben schon seit anfang an de
schön dass so viel harmonie herrscht in
diesem team wird jetzt einfach mal ein
glas vorzubereiten
überraschung überraschung ist wird das
böse allen der kelten drauf und man ist
für die halbe zeit ist hier meine
operation mit meinem einsitzen
und ich bin einfach von anfang
überfordert und machte dass gott mir
dass alle zusammen
da habe ich bloß
ich weiß von einer kokosnussmilch
allerdings die man nicht anfangs gesagt
dass alles was jetzt nicht gezeigt
wurden nicht genutzt
[Musik]
nein
ich mache jetzt meine verluste aber
wettgemacht wird erst mal einen kaffee
was sagst du mitgliedschaft etwas zu
leisten so einfach war das wie und wie
sind sie zwei verstörte meisten leute
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
vor allem machen
nun mach das doch überall verstecken
nein denn klappt wer möchte begann es
anprobieren
[Musik]
lecker oder liebe ich bin nichts anderes
mehr essen
[Musik]
das ist ein auto von das liegt
vielleicht ja gar nicht dann machen wir
doch nur ein getränk und ich wollte das
machen hat er sich nackt überaus sich
die spieler also ich hab jetzt hier
meine clip sind war davor drauf machen
das noch an
ich habe durch die einen nutzen meint
rtl
leute ich bin fertig als ich habe jetzt
mal zum einkaufen scheint mir auf es
sieht aus wie ein und ich darf das
nächste mal braucht ihren hätte ich weiß
nicht was damals gängige das gebirge
das hat mir von dem motto nicht erzählt
von sydney 2000 bei 21 20 minuten vor
dem eintreffen
ich bin auch noch nicht los ich brauche
aber noch nicht so lange das ding ist
der postbus endlich gekommen der ganzen
osterdeko ich hab so ein bisschen
osterdeko für die oster wie die als ich
mich wieder videos aber ich habe
außerdem geholt und mich schon geärgert
dass die nicht pünktlich ankommen zu
unserem dreh und ihr dass sie angekommen
und ich muss noch warten dass er hier
alles abgelehnt und dann kann ich auch
los ich würde mal sagen wir waren jetzt
mal an ein cocktail ist ein oster ei was
von oben mit dem wai sum gelb natürlich
auch dass man sich aufgemacht hätte ich
muss aber auch dazu sagen das waren
nicht die original idee also es kamen
während des prozesses darauf nicht
vorgekommen so drin gesehen habt das ist
schon das war schon bitter 18 eurem eine
waffe kaufen und erwarb vor über das duo
ab 18 aber dafür ausgeben
wenn man sich das so ist und der
geschmack ist marco alica schoko ja naja
man kann ja auch sein dass man weiß was
nicht mehr rein gemacht habe
kokosnussmilch
ok und probieren wir nicht ins auge
stechen sondern er so in die saane daten
vor weil man sonst hat man halt nur
immer nur ja bald die markus kugel diese
schokolade drin ergibt die wirklich
keinen sinn oder macht gekommen
macht ein bisschen komischen unter
geschmack naja so weit zum schoko alten
glauben aber funktionieren auch nicht
sozusagen die mango habe ich irgendwie
gar nicht geschmeckt weil sie einen
löffel eis gibt's zum strohhalm
natürlich noch ein rätsel
und dann kann man so sich mit ein
bisschen sahne und bisschen links kann
man sich noch ich weiß dass mit der
mango ist ich glaube frisch ist okay
nächster dran sich ganz ganz süß kam
aber 18 euro
mein cocktailbar na ja ich habe eine
kaffeekreationen gemacht die hoffentlich
merkt weil kaffee ist eigentlich jemand
gekauft ich habe auch sehr lustig weil
ich hab den ja wohl den teufelskreis und
dazu gibt's eine weiß ich nicht mehr
wusste was ich damit machen wir muss man
das jetzt trinken einfach treiben also
wie ihr wollt weiß ich doch auch nicht
habe ich mir nicht überlegt
du hast deine alkoholfreie version also
ich glaub da sie erfolge ich glaube das
könnte einige schmecken ist wie so ein
shake alt man muss echt sagen so
schmeckt wie so ein richtig fancy
starbucks aber muss sogar sachen drin
sie sind 105 kaffee arabica cremonesi
ruppen eis und mit schaum unterhemd und
und das ist richtig lecker weil wir noch
richtigen ein corner
aber das ist schon 'ne geile creation
aber ja es ist also ich glaube - da
hätte man also den kann man auch essen
wir diesen haben wenn er wollte aber es
schmeckt halt nicht es ist fast alle
lügen passen wenn du trinkst du auch was
vorher ja aber wieso liebe mein gott ich
habe meinen meinen namen vergessen
meiner ist das super als superman spielt
sich die kundin war und weil es einfach
ein super ist groß macht das noch mal
neu du hast so viel kreativität bewiesen
jetzt muss auch mal was kreatives kommen
das super
sie verlor das café ein kompromiss
cocktail der der ja schon zwei streicht
ziemlich eingegangen aber was soll man
machen
so ist erteilt das hier ist ein cocktail
da war habe ich mir gedacht der
eierlikör an sich ist schon ein sehr
schweres sehr intensives getränk haben
wir ja auch nicht immer sich geben
deswegen dachte ich ich gleiche dass ein
bisschen mit erfrischenden bären aus ich
wollte so einen kleinen bären mixa
reinmachen
außerdem habe ich daran gedacht die sind
ja alle info im sommer stimmen das sind
ja auch immer die ganze nacht von
influenza ankommen ist auf millipore
aufgekommen kommen wird dafür noch mal
deswegen wollte ich gerne einen drink
machen in spider oder auch gleichzeitig
ein
die alternative zu dem sonst so am
hellweg
deswegen habe ich auch zwei kilo war
aber egal was bedeutet das automatisch
gesund
also haben wir hier einen
herzerfrischenden aber erwärmenden
pamoja so heißt denn das hertie per mail
dabei müssen den dafür raum dessen
umrühren das ist ja jetzt so damit voll
ausleben
das ist aber eine ganz komische farbe
geworden war rückwärts
ich bin gespannt was passiert auf den
alkohol drin
[Gelächter]
und er bekommt also erfindung ganz weg
und ich bin so gespannt
die täterin ist in der bahn ist hier
also ich muss sagen sehr leicht
abwischen möchte ich nicht sagen
je schwerer das nicht geschafft ist aber
die eine heilige habe ich irgendwie
nicht so geschmeckt ich hab noch
umgestellt
ich habe auch tatsächlich nicht so viel
gemacht weil ich angst hatte dass er für
dich nicht mehr rein um die verletzten
homies so wie mit so noch zu kaufen
das ist kaffee drin berichtet ich glaube
die grundzutat bei rund 112 wählen werde
jetzt timos bewertung gehört haben was
sagen wie renz wer hat gewonnen
jetzt ist sie schon wieder gegen diesen
preis
aber wie kann ihnen jetzt ein cocktail
das erfahrt ihr in der nächsten folge
ein cocktail für die kommentare was
glaubt ihr wer für euch gewonnen habt
ihr könnt natürlich nicht schmeckt aber
von mallorca
[Musik]